six billion people around the globe from
every imaginable background with
incredible diversity yet despite these
differences were more similar and more
connected than you might think
who were our ancestors where do we come
from and how did we get here in April
2005 National Geographic and IBM teamed
up to find out I wanted to draw people
together to make people realize that
we're all part of an extended family and
that our DNA connects all of us into a
very tight-knit group with support from
the wait Family Foundation we launched
the Genographic project a massive
five-year effort to trace our DNA back
tens of thousands of years to our
earliest ancestors in East Africa we're
collaborating with indigenous tribes
plus hundreds of thousands of other
people around the world gathering DNA
samples to map our human history we need
to create the world's largest database
of genotypes but you're talking about
sampling hundreds of thousands of people
around the world and generating all this
genetic information we need to find a
partner it does take a great deal of
innovation to pull off this mapping of
the journey you know of humankind we
provide the technology infrastructure to
gather the data and bring it in there's
no better place to prove how we're all
connected than here at Grand Central the
crossroads of New York City and a
microcosm of diversity
[Music]
my name is Spencer Wells with National
Geographic I direct a project for them
called the Genographic project and we're
using DNA as a tool to study how people
all over the world are related to each
other would you be interested in maybe
giving us a sample it can be a part of
it yes that's contributed by DNA
absolutely maybe getting yourself tested
100% what do you think you might find
out what is your family you know I have
another question my last name is not
common in the country where I was born
we have a stick Indian an hour because I
wrote my basic heritage is Mexican
partly again but we traced it back to
Spain Massenet ting
so you'd be interested in maybe getting
yourself tested and seeing all the way
back to those ancestors and maybe even
before sure as long as it doesn't hurt
it doesn't hurt at all very simple you
swab the inside of your cheek take a few
cells send them up to the lab then you
go onto a website totally anonymously to
get the results back a few weeks later
sounds good
well let's get you started suave don't
look at any of my fillings present yet
up and down perfect then you do a second
one just to make sure we have enough of
your DNA the first thing that comes out
of the research is how closely related
we all are so you know we only started
to separate about 2,000 generations ago
which is like that a geological sense
what do you know about your family
history I know a lot of my relatives
some of them look as you do then I have
like for example my mother's father was
very dark
we all started up in Africa
years ago so you are african i'm african
under the skin another girl I see we're
not late it we could be related how do
you feel about that Oh fantastic I can't
wait for my Christmas present in just a
few weeks Cecile JW Frank and Dee Dee
will get the results of their DNA tests
and discover the mysteries of their past
so far the Genographic project has
collected over 200 thousand samples and
IBM's computational biology group has
been helping us analyze the results this
is our first chance in the history of
human civilization to look within and
learn something that actually was not
knowable before unlocking those secrets
helps us understand how we're all
connected like our four participants
from Grand Central who are about to
discover the stories of their distant
past
dee dee lives near Minneapolis where
she's been tending bar for 26 years
she's definitely a people person there
you go honey are you ready to order I'm
looking forward to seeing her again well
hi Spencer the scientist 3 National
Geographic hey DeeDee go see a great
kisser you know you start off in Africa
all those years ago just like everybody
else all over the world and around
45,000 years ago after living in Africa
for a very little group of your
ancestors left Africa and moved up into
the Middle East
40,000 years ago you have recently come
out of Africa suddenly you're living in
this icy wasteland with things like that
walking around and you've got to figure
out a way to kill them to make a living
and survive hmm what would you have done
well I would have killed him no I would
have found a guy to do it for me Joe
yeah
in Southern California
Frank is retiring soon and looking
forward to a life on the golf course he
discovers that his ancient relatives
crossed the Bering Strait during the
last ice age to become the first humans
to settle in the Americas his Aztec
blood might be for real it's quite
interesting up to the last 15 to 20
thousand years our ancestors were
extremely adaptable who survived by
hunting large mammals using
sophisticated weapons and small stone
blades and it kind of makes me
understand why I feel that I'm such a
survivor because I have AI can create
you know things out of nothing I've
always been that way we are ancient
ancient ancient people that that's that
to me is fabulous Cecille Nepal's
results revealed that her ancestors were
among the first humans to ever settle in
Southeast Asia
now cecile lives and works in new york
city but she still feels connected to
her philippine roots if there is
something that we still have that would
carry on and it's something to be proud
about new york city cop JW lives in
brooklyn with his wife and son his DNA
results confirm his Puerto Rican Spanish
and ancient African heritage but that
isn't all what was surprising was that
we were the actual first humans to ever
plant seeds and from that we generated
this huge cultivation of crops and and
we pretty much changed the face of
against mankind if you would coming from
grandparents who were farms themselves I
kind of see the relation there so pretty
interesting everybody that we met at
Grand Central that day ultimately traces
back to an ancestor in in Africa I feel
connected because we all have one common
place of origin East Africa
regardless of what our exteriors look
like regardless of how our accents may
differ our customs or holidays whatever
the case may be it all started here and
we all have that connection I think the
ultimate goal for this project is to
literally bring us all a little bit
closer together the cool thing that
comes out of this research is obviously
that we're all connected to each other
and that we scattered to the wind if you
will to populate the world over the last
sixty thousand years sponsored by
National Geographic mission programs
taking science and exploration into the
new millennium